the Joe Rogan experience especially for
people that don't train they always want
stand up fights sure
so you how did you wind up going over to
Myanmar so okay so just again I I got
myself i watch a vice documentary on
prison fight okay look at that
so the prison fight thing another that's
again for its for in Thailand for those
who don't know it's sanctioned by the
Thai departure the Department of
Correction and they didn't do I was on
the last one ever in 2014 and basically
its inmates fighting foreigners and if
the inmate wins the the sentence is
reduced whoa
yeah have you heard about this no ok
prison fight yeah I did that and we were
so basically we go into maximum security
prison outside of Bangkok
maximum-security prison and it's like a
movie man like they made a movie
actually about it recently I was on the
real deal yeah and I was with my Turkish
friend we go there they take her away
phones look at that big metal door we go
underneath I have goose bumps talking
about it and then we go 800 inmates
they're all they're all there for leader
rape gang rape murder trout drug
trafficking and they're all making it
their sentence reduced if they win a
fight yeah what if they went to fights
one guy actually it was on it was on
Showtime they didn't mention on Showtime
and he actually won the the finale you
won against an American and the he got
released a murder 21 he was actually but
that what I heard I'm correct me if I'm
wrong but you went he was in a bar and
somebody like talked about his
girlfriend touch his girlfriend he went
back he took a knife and stabbed the guy
in the neck and he got in prison for
that for murder basically then he got
out for fighting well you're fighting
very well don't go to that part of the
world with a squeamish stomach so you
was but actually those guys there they
do some mistakes but they were fighting
in lumpini they were they were like
high-level guys you know really yeah
maybe not make all champions but they
were like they knew how to fight 100
fights enough yeah so I get a guy who
was there for trafficking
methamphetamine meth Wow it was like 10
years and basically me actually maybe
you know and Barbra Jean are well he
fights in glory and he was actually he
fought for the belt against
he actually lost the belt recently and
we were me and him at the time he was
not in glory at the time we fought there
and only you know me and another Iranian
one the prison fight and what are the
rules so it's it's a three-round fight
Muhtar rules with gloves with big
pillows mmm it owns so at the time I
again my goal was always to go to
Myanmar so look look at that so
basically after this I go back to Canada
and I'm like my head is like I don't
want to be in minus 4 degrees Celsius I
you know and minus 20 in Celsius so I'm
like how can I go back to Asia and so i
go to i go to i go back i find i save
money i go back and then losing my
thoughts basically i when i when i get
that situation with arena ready we're
like we're like we're stressing for
money we're stressing for the future
III called up the prison fight promoter
and i'm and at the time I said you have
a fight for me like I need to get money
you need to know he said well I don't
promote more tiny more I promoted its
way you want to get you want to fight a
little too I'm like yes that's my juice
you know I always wanted to do this so
he's like well if you want I have this
guy is to to tio tio
is a undefeated champion let away rules
36 nice to to to to that's his real name
who's undefeated how many 36 fights that
means it's all ko right because
traditional its way it's K only 2 and we
forgot to say that it's really there's
no there's no point system no points no
how many rounds 5 rounds so what happens
if you go fire wrong
whoa you're [ __ ] the dude up that's
what happened
Wow so yeah so basically I go I said I
don't care let's fight I want it because
you just it's my dream so it's like well
how many fights you have well I have 10
with Thai fights Oh Muay Thai well he's
you know 50 fights and let's weigh and
you have 10 fights in multi well let me
let me do something
II lied on the record he said you have
40 fights ok and then I go over I go
over there only I don't care cuz my
coach Sifu Patrick and I we were always
like you know I going in like practicing
that's the mentality of it aggressivity
like fishhooking in the clinch or in the
ground either in that way no no but I
mean you could probably a fishhook if
probably probably I mean they don't care
really really yeah but as long as no eye
pokes right so anyway so I was always
ready for that I wanted that that
aggressive fights so um I go through the
fight and some kind of energy comes in
my body I don't know I don't believe in
that stuff but like I just disfigured
him like he didn't touch me much I was
using my push kick to the thighs I was
keeping that distance and then I went
inside I used my elbows and I like if
you see the fight it's it was you really
buffed up like it was pretty cool and
then that was my first fight and the
crowd like they were throwing bottles at
a little bit why were they throwing
bottles cuz they they're he's their
champion yeah but then they quickly saw
that I did my lick come on which is the
challenge gesture you know very old
challenge gesture and the they loved it
so they started what is how does that
work so basically before the fight you
put your arm like this and you you so
explain to people that are just
listening you put one arm under your
armpit so yeah for those at home so you
put your left arm under your armpit and
your arm in the air and you you hit with
your your cupped hand on the
triangle-shaped of your elbow and you
three times it actually gives me more
goosebumps before because that that's I
trigger that to the fight right and this
is a very old gesture from me amar from
the Burmese army back in the days when
you were in the trenches and they were
fighting enemies you challenged with
honor and courage your opponents and you
do that and that simulates the wing of
an eagle so they saw you do that I think
if they got fired up yeah in the rituals
yes because some of the times guys were
coming from other disciplines or the
country and they were putting their
white crew they were doing a bunch of
other things you know I embraced the
culture okay yeah so they liked it's
okay
because at first they basically they
wanted another tall white dude to get
[ __ ] by their guys I mean like I was
sent there to lose yeah
[Applause]